l'affirmation de soi en tant que pays fort même
Alors ne capturez pas, détruisez simplement les nôtres
il sera d'accord avec le pays
se voir aussi fort que l'on est
nous pouvons simplement l'emmener là-bas et le détruire là-bas
quelques villages en quelques minutes
[musique]
Je suis bénévole depuis la 14e année
à l'avant, j'ai utilisé les drones du propriétaire
pause entre la 15ème année et
A la 22ème année, il n'était pas rempli si
notre terre est pleine de repos
très beau et filmer avec des drones c'est super
belle tu peux
Il existe un passe-temps tel que la photographie aérodynamique est possible
dire que je suis aussi son partisan là-bas
il s'est avéré que mes services sont exceptionnels
en demande par l'armée Eh bien, heureusement dans
principes Nous avons décidé beaucoup, beaucoup
tâches avec l'aide de ces drones, nous allons
résoudre
certaines connaissances dans ce domaine I Mais encore
Je l'ai, et je l'ai fait un peu, c'est tout
les choses dans le complexe m'ont beaucoup ramené
intelligence rapide littéralement dans le premier
pendant la guerre, j'ai rassemblé tout ce que j'avais
Je me préparais, je comprends que la guerre peut
pour commencer
maintenant toute la vie d'une armée est basée sur
les drones, premièrement, sont les yeux de la guerre, deuxièmement -
c'est toujours un composant de choc
c'est d'abord la détection de l'ennemi
vous devez voir ce qui se passe sur celui-là
côté afin de savoir lesquels
les actions que nous devrions prendre où tirer l'artillerie
comment placer vos positions en retraite
avancer et ainsi de suite
l'intelligence a décidé de façon réaliste et
tâches humanitaires est que nous
par exemple, ils ne savaient pas ce qui se passait avec
par nos réfugiés de ce côté, c'est-à-dire
il y avait en fait un humanitaire
le couloir le long de ce talus est différent
couloir humanitaire là-bas sur ce pont
sur ce talus
nous avons découvert qu'il y avait un problème là-bas
l'eau est montée et ils ne peuvent pas
ils y ont fait une transition normale
un radeau improvisé sur lequel on peut
croiser une personne allongée, par exemple
ou tous les autres doivent faire comme ça
l'eau et puis il y avait une température
la température de l'eau y est comprise entre 3 et 4,5
alors que faire si tout le monde ne peut pas le faire et c'est en fait tout
à cause de cela, il était certain, pour ainsi dire, certain
un tel problème d'assaisonnement, nous le ferions si
Bien sûr, le fabricant est là par médiation
La Croix-Rouge a été retrouvée ici sans rhume
un petit bateau comme ça pesant 70 kg et
il a juste dit qu'ils pouvaient bien
traverser de Nous en quelque sorte si peu
civilisé au moins ce processus
dans la mesure où il pourrait être socialisé
toutes situations
[musique]
nous avons également différentes informations sur
quelque chose de détruit en qui, c'est-à-dire bien
les gens élémentaires Peut-être qu'ils savent
même envie de savoir dans quel état
leur maison
il existe différents types de drones sont complexes dans
La gestion est simple, c'est-à-dire que pour certains
drones simples, en principe, sur le mien
la persuasion est simplement prudente
et un opérateur équilibré qui peut
résoudre déjà certaines tâches à
extrêmement utile à l'avant
cela fait partie de notre travail ce que vous
si vous utilisez un drone civil, vous devez
c'est juste accepter d'être devant
prêt à être fusillé parce que
le cylindre A est visible du point de vue
trouver l'opérateur et il en serait loin
mouches C'est-à-dire que vous êtes obligé tout le temps Ot
mordent l'ennemi et ces quelques
même des centaines de mètres afin de
tu étais quelques mètres plus loin et tu es mort
où vous êtes intéressé
depuis
obus de mortier
cannon optim fait partie du travail
de l'opérateur actuel, j'espère que si
après un mois, ça change d'une manière ou d'une autre
nous aurons assez de drones
norme militaire
routes militaires Bien sûr, c'est une autre histoire
vous pouvez voler de loin
imperceptible à l'ennemi mais moi
les drones militaires sont toujours là en personne
Je n'ai pas vu mes mains depuis un mois et demi de guerre
n'a pas tenu
[musique]
pour moi une victoire signifierait
démilitarisation de la Russie
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas de véritable ennemi
pouvons-nous
ce sera une victoire, c'est-à-dire que je comprends ce qu'ils sont
théoriquement on peut y arriver
même quitté l'Ukraine
mais le rêve de la Russie sur ce qui ne restera pas
nous ne serons jamais détruits. Par conséquent, je pense que
il faudra atteindre une telle parité
opportunités militaires Quand ce sera
garanti
[musique]
si vous voulez aider l'ukrainien
merci d'envoyer des victoires à l'Ukraine
drones militaires ou aide
de l'argent par le biais de fonds caritatifs et que
Gloire à l'Ukraine nous aidera vraiment